[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are here with lash berry and he
bought me at Oscars gift bags
[Applause]
this is a 16th year that we put together
this special nominee you get back we
have no affiliation with the Oscars
look at medium-high emanated for an
Oscar yeah
[Music]
I'm going to attempt to lift this myself
see Camaro can do this
yours is a darker pink mine's a little
bit of a lighter pink yours is really
dark
oh my glittery you have a lot of glitter
and my pH look this looks so fancy it
feels like I'm doing something right for
my skin if I you do
here we go with the Shukla team's edible
jewel box hmm good one yeah oh yeah it's
a Canadian diamond so much breading
I hope you don't run like that and then
I iced it back
this is from halo purely for pets it's a
holistic pet food line they're allowing
the nominees to choose any animal
shelter to receive ten thousand bowls of
their holistic pet food donated to their
animal shelter is he only gets to pick
at the Julia Roberts redeemed last time
she was nominated which is very very
cool shut up to heaven
so this is another trip they're getting
they're getting a week at a luxury villa
in Greece this is the most valuable item
in their gift bag it's a $40,000
vacation package is up wow this is the
ultimate 12 day Tanzania adventure for
two they get the most incredible
itinerary it must feel good to lose
because you still win when all of this
stuff let's be frank
not everybody read beans everything this
is an unofficial homage at the top
nominees and it's just sort of taken on
a life of its own if you're bummed when
you don't win an award that you really
want and so this really helps consoled
them and it helps sort of ease the loss
and all that
[Music]